[Music]
hello how are you greeting héctor mejía
with his brief informative for today
wednesday april 14 according to
the south nevadas health district
47 thousand doses of the
johnson en chance vaccine have been administered here in the county
without  However, this vaccine has been
suspended due to six rare reports
across the nation of blood clots
in women,
none occurred in Nevada, although the
risks are very minimal.
Health experts recommend being aware of
symptoms such as severe headaches or
abdominal shortness of breath and  severe leg pain
contact your doctor if you feel
these effects
good news for nevada
governor sticks is the one who announced that
the state will open to 100%
by june first the state will give full control
to the counties by
may first  members of the
clark county commission will meet next
tuesday to discuss the removal
of restrictions and a safe opening plan while
after so much return to the ufc dana
white posted on twitter
early on the event and see if your sex force will be
inside the bull ring scam on July 10
with a full house that translates to
about 20 thousand fans the fight will be the
third people  with mcgregor and dustin for
king tickets go on sale this
week now we turn to the
weather forecast temperatures in the 70s
for today will stay in the
70s for the next few days however
for next week the degrees
will rise  until you reach 90 degrees
have a nice day goodbye hector mejía
and this was your brief informative
beijing be a spanish
[Music]